the british isles have long been the
epicenter of the whiskey world but the
fascination with this mysterious and
magical spirit has grown exponentially
in the past two decades
especially here in the u.s whether
you're an expert or just curious
we found the perfect guide
as sue kinder singh strolls through the
festival he created he does so as
current king
of the whiskey world young man it's a
joint pleasure as ever this is the
annual whiskey show in london single
cast and then blended at the end so you
can chew on the flavors together the
sort of comic con of the industry it's
all over the place where buyers sellers
and tasters come from around the globe
it's very different it's kind of nice
and creamier as well yeah
for sue kinder it's the latest chapter
in a remarkable story that started 50
years ago
in 1971 sukinder's parents were the
first asians to be granted a liquor
license in the united kingdom he and his
brother rajbeer would eventually work in
their shop back when everyone bought
bottles in stores
as that began to change the singh
parents began planning their retirement
they'd been in shops for
probably 20 years they had worked really
hard
business was getting pretty tough there
was a lot of competition in the area
and
when we knew this was going to happen
i spoke to my brother and said you know
we've been here for
for a while since finishing university
but now we need to go and get proper
jobs what are we going to do the family
closed the shop in 1999 but that same
year in the early days of dot-com retail
sue kinder and rajbeer formed a company
that sold bottles exclusively online
it was called the whiskey exchange
over the last 20 years it's become the
largest online whiskey retailer in the
world
both sikinder's business
and his passion you say whiskey is more
than just a drink what do you mean i
think whiskey is an experience yeah
if you speak to people what they love
about whiskey
is that they get these flavors which
make them reminisce of the past
whiskey at its heart is simple it has
just three ingredients grain water and
yeast
the magic happens when those ingredients
are fermented distilled and aged in each
distiller's distinct way
this is the whiskey
the glen levitt
scottish whiskey or scotch has long been
the gold standard you know i think you
look great man and i think i'm looking
like the money like the bomb as was
famously emphasized in the 1996 movie
swingers the scotch on the rocks please
any scotch will do as long as it's not a
blend of course uh single malt
glenolyvic plan fitting perhaps maybe
the glenn gow any glenn ireland has also
been money when it comes to producing
fantastic whiskey the us too often
sweeter varieties like bourbon in the
past two decades asia has come on very
strong
so kinder carries all of it both online
and now also in his stores including the
one we visited we've got islands here
then we've got space side there are 9
000 different varieties some priced as
high as 82 000 pounds or more than a
hundred thousand dollars some would
argue not much of a looker for 82 000
pounds am i right
it's antique
correct
i love
old historic bottles you know
anything from the 1960s 70s 80s and
prior how many bottles in your personal
collection
around 8 000
it can get real snobby i think you try
to meet people where they're at
why is that so important i actually
don't think whiskey is snobby i think
wine is snobby i actually think whiskey
is a friendly drink
most people say whiskey is best when you
enjoy it with friends
after we became fast friends
that's exactly what we did so first of
all since it's 8 am and we have a long
day ahead of us i'm gonna be sipping
best time to drink whiskey a pallet is
clean as long as you say it's okay i do
um what should we try first
first up was a 27 year old buna haben
single malt
less peaty and smoky than a typical isla
whiskey it's peppery spicy peppery yeah
it's quite textural yeah on the palate
yeah mouth coating even like a lemon
honey almost maybe yeah but into lemon
oil yeah actually right yeah it's it's
like a breakfast whiskey
it's like you're impressed yeah i am
impressed
we followed that with a far heavier 21
year old glenn farklas
before arriving at one of the fastest
growing whiskey markets of the last 20
years japan
this 12 year old yamazaki single malt
sells for 170 a bottle more than
doubling in price over the past 10 years
then there's the latest superstar
chichabu
introduced by singh two years ago that
bottle is how much
this bottle is the 2019
we launched this at 175
today at 750.
pounds which is
close to a thousand dollars yeah
taiwan's kavlon is another fast riser on
the whiskey stage thanks to a humid
climate the whiskey matures much sooner
so while only a few years old it has the
taste and feel of something much older i
mean for a three-year-old whiskey i do
like it absolutely that's superb
today the number of independent
distilleries turning out quality whiskey
is higher than ever part of the reason
why sukinder and his brother were just
able to sell the whiskey exchange to
french giant perno ricard for a small
fortune
both plan to stay heavily involved in
operations
continuing to shape the empire
50 years after their parents first made
history sitting back in your parents
shop as a kid
did you ever see
all this happening never
be on your wildest dreams
haven't had time to think
well we can think now as we look at
you look at this display i brought a
treat even though we still have 45
minutes of show left
this is so this is uh a little box that
they do 20 whiskeys that change the
world take you to the last 100 years
nice that's a cool little thing and we
have one of their branded whiskeys here
a single malt a 21 year old so this has
been sitting in the cask for 21 years
you guys were 10 when this was bottled i
love how you say that not the buddha
hobbies cheers that story was bad
it really was beautiful you know what's
so great about it they're one of the few
second generations that surpasses the
parents it really is a great success
story cheers folks i already drank mine
this is good yeah
smell it first get a little
it's delicious now what kind of is this
a scottish
it's a scar
it's a single mother it's a single mouth
scotch
it's it's a lighter skush that you get
like little pineapple
it's very fruity that's by your palate
very impressed by your palate in that
piece we're always impressed with
jeffrey